bonjour j'ai dit d'asmae merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france faites vous partie de ces
frondeurs italiens qui ont décidé de
rouvrir malgré les restrictions
alors moi je me plais particularité
c'est à dire que moi je suis resté
ouvert depuis un an sur une de mes
activités qui essaient de la boulangerie
donc je suis un peu moins touchée que
mes collègues mais c'est vrai que
j'étais sur la place mon territoriaux il
ya deux jours à observer ce qui se passe
c'est vrai alors pourquoi justement
cette manifestation expliqué noué hier
les restaurateurs d'ailleurs frondeurs
ont tout vert malgré tout au risque de
subir des sanctions
oui là et ils ont tous fermé pour une
bonne raison c'est que les restaurateurs
romains sont des gens très légitimiste
très légaliste
ils ont même inventé le droit les
romains donc il est sympa dans la rue
pour n'importe quoi là il ya une vérole
bol qui est dû à une incompréhension et
un sentiment d'injustice très profond
notamment depuis le 3ème confinement qui
a été instaurée fin mars et qu'il
devrait durer jusqu'à début mai où les
causes ne sont plus comprise alors que
l'année dernière une grande solidarité
pour les mesures nationales la région
lazio dont le rhum et la capitale et la
région la moins touchée par le virus
donc là les fermetures qui ont été
faites plus tôt par solidarité nationale
n'ont pas été comprises au moment où il
ya une grande paupérisation évidemment
de l'activité quel est l'état justement
de ce secteur en italie actuellement un
secteur très important puisque le
tourisme est très important également le
secteur du tourisme en italie c'est
encore plus important qu'en france car
c'est quand même très sport cent du
produit intérieur brut donc 13% du
produit intérieur brut qui est à l'arrêt
depuis maintenant un an et il y a une
grande différence entre les mesures
françaises allemandes ou italiennes
c'est qu'en italie vous êtes aidez sous
forme de crédits d'impôts le problème
c'est que vous ne travaillez pas le
crédit d'impôt c'est pas de l'argent qui
rentre c'est de l'argent qui dort
hélas les restaurateurs n'en peuvent
plus on fait alors comment font-ils pour
survivre alors beaucoup de restaurateurs
romains se sont acquittés familiale donc
et une grande solidarité serait ce des
pays traditionnels donc la solidarité
joue à plein peu s'en sortent les
patrons s'en sortent mais ils
manifestent surtout pour leurs salariés
ce qui est dramatique en italie c'est
qu'il ya un million de nouveaux chômeurs
est beaucoup et du secteur du tourisme
match et cela vienne bas leur patron et
leur demande de te regarder ouvrir
absolument parce que c'est la panique
c'est la panique social est ce qu'il a
dit ce qu des sanctions comme en france
on avait de même des des restaurateurs
être mises en garde à vue en italie je
pense que le pragmatisme l'a vait
emporté ce qui s'est passé il ya deux
jours c'est quelque chose de jeunes je
le répète à de très rares en italie mais
c'est un point de non retour
le gouvernement italien est un plan très
pragmatique et je suppose que plutôt que
dans les garde à vue ils vont anticiper
la réouverture avec les règles
nécessaires qui était prévu initialement
le 3 mai et dont les réouvrir le 20
avril
oui donc la situation va s'améliorer ce
que les italiens sont solidaires avec
avec les restaurateurs est ce qu'ils
viennent justement se restaurer non non
c'est ces établissements qui sont
ouverts vous avez cessé commenceront
seulement de la restauration en italie
les cafés bars et restaurants c'est un
adn qui unit la profession qu'elle
exploite et les clients et ce quelque
chose qui est un vrai manque culturel
autant que d'aller au cinéma ne pas
pouvoir aller au café ne pas pouvoir
aller au bar et la preuve en est que moi
mes clients me disent qu'ils se font
vacciner pas par peur de la maladie mais
pour retourner au restaurant ou au café
oui donc et on a vu aussi d'autres pays
mettre en place des passes à lutter pour
pouvoir aller au restaurant est ce que
l'italie est favorable aussi à ce genre
de passe pour pouvoir aller retrouver en
tout cas un semblant de vie normale
oui je prends qui sont favorables se
sont déclarés favorables sur
l'instauration de ce pass je ne sais pas
si c'est ce qui va fonctionner parce que
il est bien évident que ce soit une
organisation facile à mettre en place à
l'échelle de l'italie qui est un pays
très composite
c'est un peu comme l'allemagne scellée
province qui dirige le pays donc c'est
ce sera peut-être un peu moins simple
mais il ya des régions qui ont mis en
place des normes sanitaires très
strictes comme la sardaigne la sicile et
qui se sont retrouvés avec 0,4 vide au
bout d'un mois de d'organisation interne
donc important besoin de cdn de l'europe
l'italie a des moyens de le faire par
elle-même
il faudrait d'ailleurs coûté qu'elle se
libère un peu plus de la tutelle
européenne sur ce sujet et prendre des
décisions plus haut niveau local c'est
ce que vous préconisez donc
ah oui mais c'est ce que je préconise
mais l'italie c'est surtout une
vingtaine de régions et la région lazio
de rome est la capitale allez tout à
fait capables de prendre des mesures à
la d'ailleurs instauré quelque chose de
très malins qui s'appelait lundi rt
c'est à dire que c'est un indice qui en
fonction des places de les dissiper dans
les hôpitaux et du nombre de cas connus
vous donne le droit ou le non droit
d'ouvrir
l'indicé est de 1 et quand vous êtes au
dessous du seuil de 1 la restauration
est possible et nous sommes au dessous
du seuil de 1 depuis plusieurs semaines
et les sommes ne tueront été maintenue
par solidarité nationale c'est là que
c'est un problème
merci beaucoup c'est très intéressant
merci ahellil d'asmae d'avoir répondu ce
matin à nos questions en direct sur arte
france